we're also watching a ton of TV being at
home so are you watching all new stuff
for you catching up on the old stuff I
love everything I love new stuff I love
reality but Carl and I started the first
season of Cheers
oh never saw it never watched an episode
never watched Cheers before so this is
so crazy
so when we start a Big Bang Theory
really early on 47 years ago they said
we don't want Leonard and Penny to be
the Sam and Diane we don't want that to
happen and I never knew what that meant
like fans and press would say this might
be like yeah we don't want that to
happen and I'd be like who's Sam and I
hit like who are they talking about
night Google I have no clue and then I
thought we maybe we do want that but I
never knew and apparently I didn't take
the time to check so now that I've
wrapped the show and it's over I decided
now would be a good time to understand
what that meant
so you started watching cheers and now
do you get what a Sam and Diane
relationship is well we're only in
episode nine but I have a feeling I know
what happens before we started recording
the interview we were just chatting I
was saying compared to me you guys are
just kids just starting out I still
think of Big Bang Theory as that new
show and I still think you guys are
going places cuz I served in the Civil
War it's so funny to me that you didn't
watch cheers but of course you didn't
watch Cheers and what you just said
that's a huge compliment to our show I
feel that way about shows too that are
obviously no longer I mean especially
like friends and Frasier and Seinfeld I
watch them now and they feel so modern
to me I feel like this aired you're
gonna have this with big bang you've
already experienced it but you're gonna
have all these people that stay
connected to you through that show and
you're gonna be passing in an airport
and see it on in the background and go
like I think I remember PTSD but I don't
really know what happened you know just
depend on the hairstyle I'll know by the
hairstyle because your hairstyle changed
so much
episode almost yes every 30 months it
was differently it was 12 years so it's
a lot of different hair a lot of
different gene sizes - let me tell you
so I could tell by the clothes and the
hair and it's it's really interesting
how that that's how it connects for me
well I've been on the air for 27 years
and I will tell you this my hair style
never changed it started out looking
like a French pastry and it still looks
like a French pastry and so I have I
can't tell it's does it looks like a
really delicious like oh there's yours
there's Anna there's cream in hair
there's everything ask you something
yeah I'm dying to Gary podcast I I'm
sorry I didn't know where this was going
but sorry sorry and you know you - hey I
got a pump controller on my hand so I'm
doing justifying all right I got I
really want to get on your podcast and
was doing the podcast is just this again
I can't see you in the nightgown so but
which is a shame but you'll have the
visual now yeah that's some hot visual
don't get me wrong
you look great but when I heard Kaylee
is gonna be wearing a nightgown
I know expect didn't expect this did you
neither did Carl Carl keeps hoping for
something else but it's not happening